find the product 2x plus 8 times 2x
minus 8 so we're multiplying two
binomials so you could use foil you
could just straight-up use the
distributive property here but the whole
point of this problem I'm guessing is to
see whether you recognize the pattern
here this is of the form a plus B times
a minus B where here a is 2x and B is 8
we have 2x Plus 8 and then 2x minus 8 a
plus B a minus B what I want to do is
I'm just going to multiply this out for
us and then just see what happens
whenever you have this pattern what the
product actually looks like so if you
were to multiply this out we can
distribute the a plus B we can
distribute this whole thing the
distribute the whole a plus B on the a
and then distribute it on the B and I
could have done this with this problem
right here and it would have taken this
less time to just solve it but I want to
find out the general pattern here so a
plus B times a so we have a times a plus
B that's this times this and then a plus
B times negative B that's negative B
times a plus B so I've done the
distributive property once now I can do
it again I can distribute the a onto the
a and this B and it gives me a squared a
times a is a squared plus a times B
which is a B and now I can do it with
the negative B negative B times a is
negative a B or negative B a same thing
and negative B times B is negative B
squared now what does this simplify to
well I have an a B and then I'm
subtracting an a B so these two guys
cancel out and I am just left with a
squared minus B squared so the general
pattern this is a good one to just kind
of know a you know super fast is that a
plus B times a minus B is always going
to be a squared minus B squared so we
have an a plus B times an a minus B so
this product is going to be a squared so
it's going to be 2x squared minus B
squared minus a
eight minus eight squared 2x squared
that's the same thing as two squared
times x squared or 4x squared and from
that we're subtracting 8 squared so it's
going to be 4x squared minus 64